Speaker 1: Unfortunately, my first two stories
today are completely infuriating in a moment.
In a few moments, I'm going to talk about the
latest with the spending infrastructure bill and
just the pathetic nature of what's happened.
And we'll talk about whether at this point
progressives should just vote no and do everything
they can to kill the bill. We'll get to that. But
first, I want to start with the story of Stephen
Donziger, the attorney who now is surrendering
to prison, and it is an absolutely insane
story. If you've not been following the story,
it is just like a perfect example of so much
of what is wrong with so many different systems
that we have in the country. So let's read
the latest report from Reuters. Chevron fo
donziger surrenders after losing bid to avert
prison prison for the lawyer Why? Well, let's look
disbarred. Lawyer Steven Donziger,
who was convicted of criminal contempt
after a decades long legal battle with Chevron
over rainforest pollution in Ecuador, surrendered
to authorities Wednesday after losing his bid to
stay out of prison. The 2nd U.S. Circuit Court
of Appeals? Yeah, a couple of days ago denied Don
Zegers request to delay his six month prison term
or grant him bail. As he challenges his conviction
and sentenced, his lawyer, Ronald Kuby, said in
court documents Wednesday, he surrendered and
is in custody of the federal prison in Danbury,
Connecticut. Quote It is sadly typical of the
degraded quality of justice in this case that
the only way Mr. Danziger could prove he was not
a flight risk was to show up and be imprisoned.
Donziger is appealing his July conviction for
criminal contempt and October 1st, sentencing to
six months prison by a federal judge in Manhattan.
Now what is this all about? The contempt case
stems from post judgment orders in a civil
case in which another Manhattan judge in 2014
barred enforcement in the U.S. of a $9.5 billion
judgment against Chevron that Donziger won in an
Ecuadorian court. The judge said the Ecuadorian
judgment had been secured through bribery, fraud
and extortion. Donziger, who was disbarred in New
York last year, was charged with contempt in 2019
for failing to turn over his computer phones and
other electronic devices, among other conduct.
The New York resident has been in home detention
since August of 2019. Tuesday's second circuit
order also expedites Don Singer's appeal. So
you have a situation here where Steven Donziger
was fighting this case in Ecuador against one of
these big fossil fuel companies and rainforest
destruction. And then for what many assert and
will get to this in a moment are political reasons
and the power of corporations. This has all been
completely flipped and turned around on Danziger,
who then said, Guys, I'm not giving you my
stuff. And now he's been held in contempt
and now is being sentenced to six months for that
contempt now. It's not just me saying this sounds
wrong. The United Nations has ruled that
the entire Steven Donziger house arrest
violates international laws. This is from a few
weeks ago, close to a month ago, the U.N. human
rights body said a former environmental
lawyer's house arrest on contempt charges
was illegal and called on the U.S. to release him.
And this provides some context. Steven Danziger
in the early 1990s sued Texaco on behalf of a
group of Ecuadorian farmers and indigenous people
alleging major environmental harms by the energy
company. We've heard those stories many times.
For decades, these companies have known the
environmental damage that they were doing
through their fossil fuel business. An Ecuadorian
court ruled in favor of the plaintiffs in 2011
and ordered Chevron, which had since acquired
Texaco to pay nine and a half billion dollars.
Then Chevron countersued in the United States,
asking, accusing the lawyer donziger of bribery
and witness tampering. And then Judge Lewis
Kaplan in the U.S. ruled in Chevron's favor.
And then Donziger was hit with contempt
charges during the appeals process,
when federal prosecutors in the Southern District
of New York declined to prosecute Donziger on the
contempt charges. The judge took the unusual
step of appointing private attorneys instead.
Look at what is happening here. Rita Glavin, one
of the attorneys, previously worked for a firm
that Chevron retained. So every reason to
think this is Chevron wanting to get back at
an attorney that effectively went after them
for the environmental damage that they did.
U.S. District Judge found Donziger guilty of
contempt in July in the ruling. In its ruling,
the U.N. Working Group on Arbitrary Detention
called donziger detention arbitrary note, noting
the maximum penalty for donziger charges is
actually six months. House arrest for two years
without sentencing for something where you
would only at the most serve six months. This,
they wrote, means Mr. Donziger, having been
under house arrest since August 6th of 2019,
has already served the maximum possible penalty
four times over. In this regard, the working
group recalls that the Human Rights Committee has
argued if the length of time that the defendant
has been detained reaches the length of the
longest sentence that could be imposed for the
crimes charge, the defendant should be released.
The working groups, five international jurists,
said they were appalled by the case and said
the charges against the detention of Danziger
appears to be retaliation for his work as a legal
representative of indigenous communities as he
refused to disclose confidential correspondence
with his clients. In a very high profile case
against multinational business enterprise,
this is the worst of the worst of the worst.
This is very clearly retaliation by a company
with massive resources Chevron against the guy.
They allege that the settlement he obtained
of $9.5 billion was done through bribery,
but they've not proven that. Understand that
the allegation was well, they only got this
settlement by bribing people and fraud and so on
and so forth. It's not been proven. They managed
to make that case by dumping legal fees upon
legal fees to create a problem for Danziger.
They got to a point where he was in a position
of saying, turn over all these documents related
to your private dealings with the plaintiffs, he
said. No. Now he's in contempt, there is a maximum
sentence of six months for that, but he was held
under home confinement house arrest for two years,
even though the if found guilty, the maximum
possible sentence would have been six months.
Every aspect of this stinks it. Every effort was
made to exhaust every legal resource possible, and
I believe it was yesterday or the day before. I
think the day before it was decided that yesterday
he would turn himself over to a Connecticut prison
or institution, the Institute of Prisons or the
Board of Prisons, or whatever it's called
in Connecticut for the six month sentence.
A lot of people hadn't heard of this story.
It is absolutely and completely bonkers. And
I don't think this is the end of it,
and we're going to continue covering it